It is,
and it isn't in the short term,
it's not in the short term.
It has stabilized itself politically.
It's economy is growing.
It controls huge oil and gas resources
at a point in time where prices are very
high and it is muscling its way around
a,
its neighboring countries.
It's so called near abroad by
blackmailing and extorting and those
governments such as Ukraine and Georgia
and so forth and even potentially
sending troops to intervene and other
areas.
So in a way it seems,
wow,
Russia is back,
but the longterm picture,
obviously he's different,
uh,
in the long,
long term picture is that they've lost a
large chunk of their territory by the
Judah,
the collapse of the Soviet Union.
Their population is undergoing a
staggering for you fall.
People talking about Italy,
you know,
experiencing population decline.
Russia is probably the most steep in the
whole world.
There's,
they lose something like a 500,000 of
their population a year due to either
immigration or death,
uh,
due to various causes.
So in the long term picture from that
point of view isn't very good.
Uh,
they also have a lot of Chinese
migration into the country,
into the far east.
So areas,
parts of the Russian Far East
territorially that are Russia on the map
don't look like Russia in person.
So that's a huge problem to think about
as well.
Then the authoritarian system isn't
necessarily stable.
Oil prices aren't necessarily going to
be this high forever.
There's a lot of reasons why the current
resurgence is really just a blip and the
longer term picture of Russian decline
very much still holds.
Well.
Europe already does encroach on Russia's
territory in the sense that between NATO
expansion and EU expansion,
they more or less are up against the
borders of Russia,
the Baltic countries they are,
and the relationship with Ukraine,
which is deepening,
is also getting it in that direction as
well as at the countries of the
caucuses,
Georgia and Armenia and Azerbaijan.
So gradually Europe is certainly
encroaching on Russia as much as Europe
would serve as much as Russia would like
to be encroached on.
And D in Finland,
there was a debate about what
relationship to have with NATO and the
EU and whether to actually deepen those
ties,
yet more evidence of how like it or not,
uh,
Russia basically is left with only
Russia and a diminishing influence
outside its own borders.
Nuclear weapons are still there.
It has the second largest nuclear
arsenal in the world,
but it is,
um,
not the weapon of choice in the 21st
century.
And of course,
Russia only has two major population
centers or economic hubs.
So it obviously faces serious
retaliation.
So the last country in the world that
would be wise to use nuclear weapons
would be roger.